Gears of War 4 is coming out can you
believe it's been 10 years since the
original game it's crazy to think that
there's been one two three yeah even for
games covering the emulsion laced world
of sera so I think it's worth a trip
down memory lane to remember the dealth
team the locusts the jacks and the
Carmine's in one of the most beloved
third-person shooter action war video
games there is in the early 2000s epic
games were doing work they had since
released the 3d FPS unreal
which spawned a series of unreal games
including Unreal Tournament and an
engine of the same name they were
looking to create a fresh IP utilizing
the Unreal Engine 2 and created the
building blocks of a military themed
game focusing on territory control
unreal engine lead programmer James
Golding stated the team was making a
class-based battlefield style game with
a focus on multiplayer and a deployable
mech they called it on real warfare
sounds pretty good but epic had to turn
their focus to the Unreal Tournament
series for a time and when they returned
to the project they came to the
conclusion that a single-player game
would be a better direction a decision
that was widely stressed by
up-and-coming designer Cliff Bleszinski
influenced by three key titles Blues in
ski Beyond mold unreal warfare -
something a bit out of epics comfort
zone first was a cover based system
inspired by Killswitch to mix up the
standard military shooter gameplay next
Bionic commandos movement specifically
moving from platform to platform to get
closer to the objective but the biggest
of these three is Resident Evil 4 which
not only changed the perspective to
over-the-shoulder
but began a shift and tone to a dark and
brooding horror game eventually unreal
was dropped off the title altogether and
warfare made its debut at GDC 2002
revealing for soldiers exploring dark
catacombs and caves in a sci-fi
post-apocalyptic scenario but the game
would keep cooking for another four
years
being reworked and retooled from less of
a traditional army game to
a bit more sci-fi a bit more gory a bit
more chainsaw Gunny they had to fight
for it but Epic Games pushed hard to
keep the little chainsaw that could and
they were rewarded with a positive
reaction at e3 2005 now on to the Unreal
Engine 3 epic games had their sights set
on convincing Microsoft to increase the
RAM of the Xbox 360 from 256 megabytes
to 512 the game could run in 720
glorious P they also added Rob Ferguson
as executive producer for the series and
then it was up to the team to finish the
game in time for holiday release in 2006
[Music]
on November 7 2006 Gears of War made its
debut on the Xbox 360 locus Queen Mira
tells the tale of an ongoing war between
humanity and underground dwelling
reptilian humanoids the locust toured in
between the lines however the story is
one of constant warren struggle not just
between species but between humanity
itself a short history of the planet
Sara reveals a violent past between two
competing governments it abruptly ends
when one of them uses the hammer of dawn
to just wipe out another city and force
a treaty not long after that treaty was
emergence day where locusts executed a
planned attack across the planet taking
out a lot of humans this event basically
sets the tone for a dark and desperate
time where a small group of soldiers
within the coalition of ordered
government's or cogs lead a Hail Mary
mission to save the world Jack
the journey begins with Marcus Fenix a
former war hero
now I'm prisoned for abandoning his post
about 14 years from that fateful
emergence day after being broken out by
his friend Dominic Dom Santiago he leads
a ragtag team of soldiers including the
feisty tech specialist Baird and the old
thrash ball hero Coltrane on a journey
to discover a weakness within the Locust
Horde and come to terms with teamwork
and trust you shouldn't take that under
advisement Gus now move it
yes mechanically this game really sets
itself apart from other shooters at the
time it had a focus on moving between
points for cover you grow to love
inanimate objects like car doors and
bricks a concrete because it's your only
refuge from the buckets of bullets being
poured out from enemy bases battles
required tactics and observation of
surroundings for success such as pushing
a car down an alley for cover with four
weapon slots players got to freely pick
up and try a variety of weapons quite
fresh to contemporary shooters you might
get excited to use your Lancer gun which
had an attached chainsaw only to be
enamored with explosive torque foes or
the impact the feel of the hammer of
dawn the guns also came with a nice
added touch of a reload minigame we're
pressing a button at the right time gave
you additional damage but messing up
that button press embarrassed you plenty
[ __ ]
the enemies were something out of a
sci-fi horror that would both excite you
and make your skin crawl there's not too
many feelings like the first time being
trapped in a building with a berserker
and learning you can't just shoot him to
death small speedy wretches move quickly
and release the most upsetting scream
and there's nothing quite like the
entrance of a corpse er
split-screen and Xbox Live offered co-op
play you could continue the next mission
alone or co-op without losing your place
there's also team-based multiplayer for
up to 8 players which was added in
development at the last minute by the
way between multiplayer in the full
campaign there was more than enough run
and gun action to pleased fans and
please fans it did
people like eva gears it was a hit the
day it was released selling 1 million
copies in its first two weeks and
eventually go on to sell almost 6
million worldwide just two years later
critically it was also well received
with it winning multiple awards
including game spots game of the year it
was also a PC release with added
chapters but that one didn't sell so
well so let's move on yes everything was
coming up millhouse for Epic Games with
all that praise seemed only natural that
a sequel would be right around the
corner especially considering the ending
left us with pretty much a huge
cliffhanger although the Delta Squad did
succeed in releasing a light math bomb
in the heart of the locust tunnels queen
locust mira escaped and she plotted her
revenge
but to survive is to endure and prosper
and we have most certainly
on the exact date two years after the
original game released Gears of War 2
launched for the Xbox 360 following the
story from the first game mirror
regroups the Locust Horde and finds a
new way to attack humanity from
underground
it's a giant worm reasonably called a
riff worm to eat away at the dirt under
the last city Jacinto and sink it we
come back to our friends that Delta
Squad plus a squeaky-clean new carmine
to take down the worm mechanically this
game isn't too far from the original
staying true to cover based gameplay
that we're used to besides a few new
guns not that we should ignore the
flamethrower or anything and some new
vehicles you're playing something that
should feel pretty similar more about
how the environments lend themselves to
the story and set the game apart almost
immediately you're riding assault
Derek's and being attacked by mortars
and rivers walking through the locust
tunnels and inside a rift worm creates a
nice change of scenery for the game even
if it's pretty dark and depressing and a
little gooey down there riding river and
broom AK is truly the cherry on top of a
wild adventure for this crew but the
second in the series is where the
writing really starts to connect the
heart of the Delta Squad with their
place in this war-torn world regardless
of how bad the circumstances get Coles
always got a good line so these locusts
Beach is a process flashbacks to DOM and
his wife convey a sense of peace and
happiness only to find that she's in
grave danger most of the game is spent
searching for her which culminates in
one of the most emotional scenes of the
entire series but it also helps pave the
way for the emotional rollercoaster of
the crew in their final struggles we get
a better look at Lamb Ben who are
locusts mutated by exposure to emulsion
and they don't particularly care for
humans or locusts in a series surrounded
by war it seems only natural that the
locust and lambent would also be at odds
with Jacinto very likely to fall anyway
Marcus makes the call to sync Jacinto
and flood the locust phase turning the
tide of a losing battle Mira and some of
the Horde still manage to escape
leading up to what will be the
culmination of a brutal and bloody
one leaves behind a lasting legacy but
so often the legacies that we leave
I'm not the ones that we
so this is how it ends on September 20th
in 2011 the highly anticipated third and
final part of the trilogy starts off
with incredible dark and depressing
scenarios it pretty much sets the tone
for the rest of the game humanity is now
in crisis and trying to find a safe
place of refuge
both locust and lambent are out for
blood forcing a difficult journey for
Marcus and Dom who try to get to an
island as everything around them is
crumbling lambent take a larger role in
this game being much more aggressive
with humanity and attempt to just wipe
them out the land is a good way to
change up the gameplay because they tend
to explode or run really fast or just be
really creepy in general and as expected
gears mixes up traditional gameplay by
putting the player in spectacular
locations large barges moving across the
sky and submarines under the surface of
the water and they also added iced tea
which is just a really good touch got
some nerve coming around here asking for
favors [ __ ] you also get
another deep dive into the Delta Squad
and their motivations and a character
long overdue for his personal victory
gets one
the main story arc though focuses around
Marcus trying to get to his father a man
who's been part of the journey the whole
time just mostly in audio records and
technologies but the real relationship
has always been in front of us the whole
time story of two war heroes working
together through conflict and death
working together to make something
better for Humanity it's not only
halfway through this game that Dom makes
a choice that will dramatically change
the face of the battle and the series
forever
ah
[Music]
[Music]
Marcus carries on to find his father
Adam and come to terms with what he's
been working on although Adams been
working against his will to help the
locus he also created a device that can
take out everything locust lambent
emulsion all of it all of its gotta go
not after Marcus has lost so much he's
got to come to terms with what his
father is done and what he has to do to
prevent humanity from total annihilation
Marcus's anger comes to a head in a
final battle between him and Meera
it's a short but satisfying battle and
that's pretty much it
humanity is saved but it's really just
the scraps of what's left of it
there's really not much left of the
future but at least there is one with
the trilogy wrapped up it makes sense
that you'd see some changes behind the
scenes in 2012 Cliff Bleszinski
announced his departure from Epic Games
epic teamed up with people can fly to
work on a fourth entry in the Gears of
War series by 2013
there's just not as much to say about
judgment not just because the game isn't
as beloved as the original trilogy but
also because mechanically and
thematically it really differentiates
from the first three games open
environments are replaced with smaller
contained areas and those themselves are
contained within six chapters and
campaigns it's also the only game where
you only have two weapons lost instead
of four changing up a few things
considered quite gears an attempt to mix
up the series the story also takes a
turn in the form of flashbacks from
Baird and other team members that begin
from before the events of the very first
game it's nice to look into the other
aspects of Baird and Cole's personality
as well as a deeper glimpse into the
lore of Sarah and increasing tensions
within humanity before the war overall
it's a game that favors action over
immersion you'll be sawing a lot of
dudes in half but the heart of the story
isn't really in there not the thing
about Gears you come to know and love
certain things about each game knowing
you'll find cog tags hidden throughout
the world knowing that you'll see a
carmine and root for that survival
knowing that you'll depend on Jack to
open a door knowing you're gonna hear
the name on you we kind of get ourselves
stuck between a rock and a hard place
where we just want the gears that we
already love but we don't want the same
thing either epic created everything
gears for seven years but on January
27th 2014 Microsoft announced the
purchase of the entire Gears of War
franchise from Epic Games Rob Ferguson
was thrown in to sweeten the deal to
oversee the franchise at the studio the
Coalition at e3 2015 Rob talked about
the new look for Gears of War 4 and the
setting which is 25 years after Gears of
War 3 with Marcus's son now the lead
character everyone recently got a peek
at 20 minutes of footage from the
prologue which is a look into the
central moments in the Gears time line
including emergence day and a battle
from the pendulum wars after the
prologue though everything is kind of a
mystery we'll have to wait until October
11th to see how they've treated the
world of Sarah and the remaining people
that reside there we've seen reboots
time and time again we've seen trilogies
unable to be touched we've seen half-ass
attempts at capitalizing on a known
franchise
but with years there's always the
ability to make something with meaning
something with heart and something we'll
talk about for years to come
please be good